hey 42 here are we alone in the universe
of all of Humanity's most profound
ponderings whilst perched on porcelain
Thrones that one's probably the biggest
it's also one of the most difficult to
answer
as of today nobody knows if Earth is a
singular Oasis or simply one amongst
countless Celestial sanctuaries
harboring life
despite this uncertainty it's a question
worth asking because For Better or For
Worse first contact with an alien race
would arguably be the most important
event in the entire 200 000 year history
of our species surpassing even the
invention of the wheel or the discovery
of fire
the knowledge that there are over
intelligent species out there would
fundamentally change what it means to be
human irrevocably altering our
understanding of both the universe and
our place within it but here's the thing
it might have happened already and I'm
not talking about some Area 51
government conspiracy crap I mean we may
have already received an unambiguous and
well-documented message from the Stars
this is the story of the wow signal
Mankind's first contact with aliens
maybe
surfsharkvpn keeps you safe and private
by covering up everything you do online
surfsharkvpn lets you travel the world
virtually by changing your virtual
location so you can visit websites that
might be blocked in your home country or
if you are physically traveling
surfshark also lets you connect via your
home country so you don't miss out on
all your home Comforts such as streaming
video content from home that might be
blocked whilst you're traveling there
are over 3 200 servers in 100 countries
so anywhere you go you'll find a server
that fits your needs I like
surfsharkvpn's multi-hub feature that
lets you put two VPN servers between you
and your online destination for even
more privacy and security and I get a
lot of use from surfshark's IP Rotator
feature which constantly changes your
device's IP address without losing your
VPN connection I often use surfsharkvpn
to access my online banking safely even
on public Wi-Fi there's no chance I
would ever do that without a VPN vpns
also keep your location and download
history private so you can send and
receive files securely quite simply
surfsharkvpn is an essential tool and by
using the Code 42 you'll benefit from an
83 discount plus free extra mums for
free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description below so
don't miss out and thanks to surfshark
for sponsoring this video
on the 15th of August 1977 Jerry Emin
was sitting in his kitchen scrutinizing
a substantial stack of seemingly
senseless scribblings each page was
covered in random numbers and letters as
though someone had sneezed on them
whilst eating alphabet soup but as a
research scientist with the seti project
Jerry Emmons trained gays could discern
this Cosmic code because it was data
from one of the world's most powerful
radio telescopes nicknamed Big Ear
unlike regular telescopes that use
lenses and mirrors to magnify visible
light telescopes like big ear are
designed to gather radio signals
originating in D base and it was this
info that was contained in Jerry emin's
Alpha Betty spaghetti printouts each of
the 50 columns represented a different
frequency child and the numbers and
letters within those columns displayed a
strength of any incoming radio signals
of that frequency low numbers meant weak
signals background noise mostly and high
numbers meant stronger signals The
Columns were only wide enough for a
single character so signals above a 9
were assigned a letter instead a meant a
signal strength of 10 B 11 C 12 and so
on
Jerry had searched through literally
thousands of pages like these during the
four years Big Ear had been hunting
aliens without finding anything of
particular interest but on that fateful
day in 1977 his eye was drawn to a
signal that looked like nothing he'd
ever seen before
6 EQ
uj5 an alphanumeric string so startling
that Jerry circled it in red pen and
Scribbles the now famous wow annotation
the so-called wow signal had several
attributes that made it so remarkable to
start it was a staggering 30 times
stronger than background radio noise it
had also only registered in one of big
ears 50 frequency channels meaning it's
what we will call a narrow band signal
narrow band radio signals aren't
typically made by natural sources
they're generated by technology as soon
as he saw the signal Jerry Emin knew
that he might be looking at Humanity's
first contact with aliens but as Carl
Sagan once said extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence the first
thing the seti team had to do was make
sure the wow signal really was something
extraordinary observing the world for a
radio telescope is a notoriously finicky
business for the simple reason that
radio waves are absolutely bloody
everywhere a cesus cacophony of cosmic
climber including Stars black holes and
quasars constantly emit radio waves like
drug Gunslingers in an Intergalactic
Saloon
closer to home terrestrial Technologies
also rely on radio waves TVs and
telephones only compounding the chaos if
anyone was going to take the wow signal
seriously it had to be demonstrated that
it hadn't come from any of these other
sources
Galactic radio noise could be swiftly
eliminated because the wow signal was
far too strong other natural phenomena
like stars and quasars could also be
ruled out because they emit radio waves
across a wide range of frequencies not a
single narrow band They also tend to
amidst them constantly over millions
even billions of years but when Big Ear
listens to that same section of Sky the
following night the mysterious signal
was gone finally interference from
earth-based technology also seemed
extremely unlikely the wow signal traced
an unmistakable bell-shaped curve
matching the expected signature of a
space-based source passing directly over
the telescope earth-based interference
on the other hand typically produces
sporadic pulses
so the signal was seemingly artificial
and came from the cosmos
that must mean it was aliens right well
not necessarily the scientists first had
to confirm that the signal hadn't come
from our own radio wave producing
space-based technology satellites
it didn't take them long you see in the
late 70s fewer than 300 satellites
orbited Earth and none of them were
supposed to be nearby on the night in
question moreover big ears data showed
that the wow signal Source was
stationary relative to the stars in
other words to have produced a while
signal one of the fewer than 300
satellites in existence would have had
to have been in exactly the right part
of the sky at exactly the right time
moving in exactly the right direction at
exactly the right speed to match the
motion of the Stars around it in my book
that's pretty conclusive but the
evidence against the satellite Theory
doesn't stop there you see it wasn't
just a strength and signature of the
wild signal that was so unusual it was
also the frequency it was resonating at
1420 megahertz
that's Incredibly Close to something
called the hydrogen line the frequency
at which hydrogen atoms naturally emit
radio waves the significance of that
seemingly random coincidence might not
be immediately obvious so let me explain
hydrogen the customer says most copious
element is so abundant that sensitive
radio telescopes are able to detect its
Perpetual radio hum everywhere thus
tuning Our telescopes to this particular
frequency unveils a wealth of knowledge
about the fabric of the universe
succinctly put
1420 megahertz is arguably the single
most important radio frequency for any
young civilization seeking Cosmic
comprehension chances are if we're
listening to it then so is everyone else
out there for the very same reasons you
probably know where I'm going with all
of this contacting a distant
civilization across the boundless
expanse of space is a tricky business
there's no way of knowing what languages
they speak even what sense organs they
might possess but the hydrogen line is
universal any alien wanting to be heard
would be wise to transmit at 1420
megahertz
for this and other reasons one four two
zero megahertz is an internationally
protected radio frequency reserved
solely for scientific research nobody
else is allowed to use it going back to
the satellite view for a second two have
produced the wow signal Not only would a
satellite need to have been in the right
part of the sky at the right time moving
in the right direction at the right
speed it would also need to have been
transmitting on an illegal frequency so
it was clear the Y signal wasn't the
result of interference or
misidentification nor a malfunction the
telescope was tested thoroughly and no
issues were found plus it would have
been a hell of a coincidence of a random
instrumentation error perfectly
replicated the exact signal researchers
were seeking so to summarize the wow
signal was a narrow band radio signal
that so far as we know must have been
generated by some kind of Technology it
originated in space it wasn't the result
of Earth based interference and it was
sent on a very specific frequency that
we believe aliens might use to contact
us all of this leads me to one pretty
obvious question why the isn't the
wow signal considered to be the most
important scientific discovery in the
history of the human race well that
rather rude question has a very simple
answer since that fateful day in 1977
the wow signal has never been detected
again we scoured the skies with far
bigger and better telescopes than big
ear but almost 50 years on and there's
been nothing thus a whisper
until we verify the signal through a
second observation doubts will always
linger about its nature and origin true
nobody has provided a compelling
non-alien explanation but that doesn't
automatically mean there isn't one we
may just have missed something or
perhaps the signal was generated by some
kind of natural phenomenon that we
haven't discovered yet without more data
from further observations it's
impossible to say for sure as the years
pass without the return of the wow
signal doubt steadily seeps in
after all if this was the interstellar
equivalent of E.T slipping into our DMs
why suddenly cut the transmission
it's also worth mentioning that big ear
detected no modulation of the signal
meaning so far as we can tell there was
no actual information encoded within it
again why if an alien intelligence went
to all the trouble of getting in touch
across the Galaxy wouldn't it have made
sense to actually say something almost
50 years on from the detection of the
wow signal it continues to both
Fascinate and frustrate the scientific
Community back in 2017 an astronomer of
somewhat dubious credentials claimed to
have traced a signal back to a couple of
previously uncataloged comets enveloped
in radio wave emitting hydrogen gas
clouds
several astronomers with significantly
more impressive credentials soon pointed
out that the comments in question
wouldn't have been in the right part of
the sky when the wow signal was recorded
and even if they had been comets don't
produce the right kind of radio signals
in the first place in short it was a
bust but the fact the story made
headlines Around the World shows that
people are still intrigued by this most
mysterious misf more recently as we've
begun to map our galaxy in Greater
detail astronomers have attempted to
pinpoint the exact star system from
which the wow signal might have
originated during a 2020 survey Spanish
astronomer Alberto Caballero identified
66 stars in the Sagittarius
constellation as possible candidates
work is already on the way to search
these stars for signs of life will we
find an advanced civilization orbiting
one of them wondering why the hell it's
taking us so long to reply to their
voicemail message
only time will tell
after recording the wow signal the Big
Ear telescope continued its search for
extraterrestrial life until 1995. making
it the longest running seti project ever
conducted in the 22 years Big Ear
patiently listened to the radio wave
Whispers of the universe it never
detected anything remotely similar to
the wow signal again
which to this day remains one of
science's greatest enigmas thanks for
watching